cliff where were you last year I was in
the Philippines I I'm sorry I'm late
well we're glad you're here now and
would you be good enough to read the
nominations for the short subjects award
write in live action the nominees are
blake doug jackson producer the magic
machines john keller stern producer
people supe mark Merson producer and
here is the envelope will you announce
the winner happily the winner is the
magic machines
when I decided to submit magic machines
to the Academy I was warned by my
friends who were very kind but it it
touched on some things that were
controversial and it was really
something from another generation but
the fact that it's touched you and that
you've chosen to honor it in this way
way means that there can't be such a big
gap between us after all I thank you the
nominees for the cartoon short subjects
are it's tough to be a bird Ward Kimball
producer of men and demons John and
faith Hubley producers walking National
Film Board of Canada
Ryan Larkin producer will you announce
the winner cliff right the winner is
it's tough to be a bird Ward Kendall
I want to thank all the wonderful talent
out of Disney Studios who helped make
this possible and I want to thank all of
the bird lovers and bird watchers in the
Academy also want to extend my
condolences to the unfortunate seagulls
in Santa Barbara